à noter que le président américain joe
biden se rendra vendredi justement
pologne pour discuter avec son homologue
andré duda de la manière de répondre à
cette crise humanitaire le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky appel lui
l'union européenne à cesser tout
commerce avec la russie alors qu'une
réunion a lieu en ce moment à bruxelles
volodymyr zelensky qui s'exprimait hier
en visioconférence devant les
parlementaires israéliens de la knesset
on va décrypter ça avec vous vilalta
rabais bonjour
volodymyr zelensky qui a demandé aux
parlementaires israéliens de faire un
choix de soutenir l'ukraine car depuis
le début les israéliens joue un jeu
d'équilibriste oui alors volodymyr
hélène ce qui est allé même encore plus
loin que ça devant la knesset donc on
sait un le président ukrainien a
l'habitude ça fait partie de sa
stratégie de communication lorsqu'il
s'exprime devant un parlement étranger
bien de créer l'empathie en faisant des
parallèles entre la guerre qui se passe
en ukraine et des événements historiques
et relativement traumatisant pour le
pays concerné typiquement devant le
bundestag allemand il a évoqué le mur de
berlin devant le congrès américain il a
évoqué par l'arborent élan septembre et
là devant la knesset vous avez dit une
partie de ce qu'il a de ce qu il a de ce
qu'il a dit devant les députés
israéliens mais il a aussi fait et à ce
stade on va rappeler que volodymyr
zelensky est d'origine juive il a aussi
fait un parallèle entre la shoah fait la
guerre en ukraine dans son pays et la
shoah et cette fois ci bien sa stratégie
de com n'a pas semblé vraiment
fonctionner comment bien passé c'est un
petit peu moins bien passé
directement sur twitter le ministre de
la communication
israéliens a réagi il a écrit la guerre
est terrible mais la comparer aux
horreurs de la shoah et à la solution
finale et révoltante et dans la presse
israélienne ce matin l'ambiance est
assez froide un vis-à-vis du du
président ukrainien puisque arrête donc
le quotidien de gauche s'est contenté
simplement d'un factuelle sans
commentaire le jerusalem post nous dit
que sa déclaration a provoqué un tollé
parmi les députés is it le leader du
groupe du groupe religieux à la knesset
qui qui qui lui aussi parle de
comparaison ridicule avec los locos et
enfin le journal israël aujourd'hui qui
est en hébreu lui titre carrément un
discours à la limite de la négation de
l'holocauste à volodimir zelensky qui a
ensuite estimé que jérusalem serait un
bon endroit pour mener des pourparlers
de paix avec moscou est ce que la russie
aurait tant d'intérêt oui alors c'est là
là c'est très intéressant parce que en
fait le premier dirigeant étranger à
s'être rendu à moscou après le
déclenchement de la guerre en ukraine et
bien c'est naftali bennett le premier
ministre israélien il a rencontré
vladimir poutine début mars ils se sont
parlés pendant cinq heures rien n'a
filtré de cette conversation mais alors
pour répondre à votre question pourquoi
la russie éventuellement pourrait
finalement accepté une médiation
israélienne ir abords des raisons
culturelles il faut savoir que vladimir
poutine a déclaré en 2011 qu'israël
était pratiquement russophone pays
pratiquement russophones et en 2012 que
israël faisait carrément partie du monde
russes pourquoi vladimir poutine dit ça
parce que 15% de la population
israélienne c'est à dire 1,5 million
d'israéliens sont en fait des
ressortissants de l'ex urss c'est-à-dire
de russie d'ukraine d'ouzbékistan etc et
qui sont donc russophone par ailleurs
qui dit israélien d'origine russe dit
également oligarques russes qui ont une
nationalité israélienne et je vous donne
par exemple roman abramovitch qu'on
connaît bien qui est le propriétaire du
club de football de chelsea qui est
alors sous sanction au royaume uni mais
pas du tout en israël et on a trois
autres oligarques qui sont sous sanction
royaume uni qui ont la nationalité
israélienne et qui ne sont absolument
pas sanctionné en israël alors enfin la
troisième raison c'est les stratégies
que cette fois ci il ya une déclaration
de guerre à la pid qui est le ministre
des affaires étrangères israélien qui a
déclaré le 20 février nous avons une
frontière commune avec la russie ait
cette frontière c'est la frontière avec
la syrie pourquoi parce qu'on le sait
depuis 2014 2015 précisément la russie
soutient à bout de bras le régime de le
régime de bachar al assad les troupes
russes l'armée russe est en syrie et par
ailleurs la russie et allié dans la
région avec l'iran or et c'est là que ça
se devient un petit peu tendu pour les
israéliens l'iran c'est évidemment
l'ennemi numéro 1 d'israël et la russie
si israël ne va pas dans son sens peut
très bien jouer de ce levier avec la
milice du hezbollah qui est à sa
frontière au liban et en syrie pour
faire pression sur l'état hébreu donc
quand on mélange un petit peu tout ça il
ya un débat très vif en ce moment en
israël dans la communauté russophone à
propos de la guerre en ukraine quand on
additionne tout ça et bien finalement la
russie pourrait se dire pourquoi pas
israël en tant que médiateur parce que
évidemment israël est aussi un pays
allié au bloc occidental merci beaucoup
mais il a l'air pur
[Musique]